when we think about brain neurons are
not the only cell type there are glial
cell types like astrocytes microglia and
oligodendustrite they talk to each other
and regulate brain function neuron glial
interaction is super important
astrocytes are important glial cell that
regulate neuronal activity forms the
blood-brain barrier release glue
transmitters which can modulate neutral
activity astrocytes has two key function
one is to create the blood brain barrier
and the second is to
regulate the synaptic activity so the
astrocytic nfit forms the blood brain
barrier actually and astrocyte can form
the Tris per typed synapse with the
neurons and secrete gliotransmitter to
influence neural activity astrocytes are
not homogeneous population they are
highly heterogeneous
and astrocytes have reactive States and
these reactive astrocytes are implicated
in Huntington disease Alzheimer's and
ALS watch the full video to know more